les images étaient très et parade c'est
juillet mais qu'est ce qui reste
à moins dans la tête pour les images
c'est le son de se réveiller en sursaut
puis là je me suis dit j'ai lépaule aux
jets texter téléphoner appelé texter
texte et téléphonie puis j'étais
toujours sans réponse peut venir
c'est une des catastrophes ferroviaires
les plus meurtrières au canada pour ce
qu'ils ont vécu de près c'est la pire
nuit de leur vie la pauvre brûler sur le
corps il y avait déjà ce trottoir états
unis et qui pleurait était en panique on
va tous mourir mais ce qui s'est passé
après la tragédie est aussi un drame car
dans l'ombre de la dévastation et n'y a
pas que les secours qui s'activent très
loin de là aux etats unis les avocats se
prépare une course il commencé ils se
sont rués sur ces gens sans même les
connaître c'est criminel
ici aux etats unis c'est un cas
classique c'est chacun on se sent
manipulé
on est une machine à faire du profit
parmi les premiers sur les lieux
c'est tom willie garcia discret
énigmatique qui est il et comment as-tu
n'empocher plus à lui seul que chacune
des familles endeuillées de lac mégantic
[Musique]
deux personnes qui sont mortes
la chaleur est accablante
deux semaines après l'explosion d'un
train au centre ville de lac-mégantic
les recherches avancent péniblement
écoutez ça faisait quelques semaines que
la tragédie est arrivé on n'avait même
pas nos corps on n'arrête pas nos corps
on spécule encore sur les causes de
l'accident mais on peut déjà prévoir des
poursuites de centaines de millions de
dollars en plus de mma une trentaine de
compagnies sont en cause dont le
canadien pacifique des pétrolières et
les propriétaires d'un wagon citerne des
firmes d'avocats américaine au flairé la
bonne affaire et sont déjà sur place
et quoi de mieux pour se faire voir que
les télés ses avocats américains et un
os qu une famille vienne leur confier
une première poursuite aux états unis
c'est un point tournant
le lendemain de cette apparition à la
télé ils tiennent une réunion
d'information dont le succès dépasse
toutes les attentes reconnaît anne
mercier l'avocat québécois qui les
aident les gens me voir à la pelletée on
avait de la noire à fournir aux gens qui
venaient nous quoi du moment où on a
fait cette entrevue à la télé les gens
se ruaient aux pompes cloud
[Musique]
ginette cameron se souvient plutôt
d'avoir reçu un appel du bureau de hans
mercier sa fille geneviève avait 28 ans
elle rêvait d'une carrière artistique
mais tout a pris fin en musique a fait
la nuit du 6 juillet on nous a convoqués
à une réunion à savoir si on voulait
faire partie d'un recours collectif ont
recours intellectuelle - ben je voulais
pour aller dans aucun recours parce que
je me disais que ma fille n'avait pas de
tout
malgré ses réticences ginette décide
d'aller à la rencontre
elle est assise en retrait au fond de la
salle lorsque l'on s'approche que
quelqu'un qui est venu voir médecin
madame aimeriez vous que la même chose
arrive à une autre maman comme vous
alors finalement est mort ou picasso à
plusieurs reprises
ceux qui veulent vous voir ben je pense
que c'est m garcia m garcia est tout
sauf un avocat c'est celui qui
n'apparaît pas dans cette image
même s'il fait partie du groupe c'est un
homme qui préfère rester dans l'ombre
et pour cause d'où il vient certains
l'accusent de contourner la loi pour
profiter de ses victimes
la légende de will et garcia remonte à
presque 30 ans en 1989
une collision entre un camion de
livraison et un autobus scolaire tourner
au drame à itunes une petite ville du
sud du texas
l'autobus plonge dans un ravin le bilan
est lourd
rené guérin était le procureur en chef
du district or les toilettes
21 enfants qui se rendait à l'école ont
perdu la vie c'est une immense tragédie
la longue carrière de rené guerra comme
procureur du district est resté marqué
par cet accident à cause du scandale qui
a suivi des avocats sans scrupules
s'était servie de policiers d'employés
de la morgue et d'ambulanciers pour
solliciter les proches des victimes
une pratique illégale au tecdax hautes
exigences et dans la plupart des autres
états on désapprouve ses chasseurs
d'ambulances comme on les appelle tous
les cas parce qu'ils choisissent des
victimes vulnérables qui risque de
signer un contrat qui n'est pas à leur
avantage
la sphère épique entre autres un
infirmier auxiliaire et ambulanciers de
fin de sept ans il s'appelle willy
garcia au monde je ne sais pas c'était
sans doute un bon infirmiers auxiliaires
pourquoi il a changé à cause de l'argent
hezemans et c'est de l'argent facile
trois avocats sont accusés voulaient
garcia lui obtient l'immunité complète
en échange de son témoignage
il ne sera plus inquiété par la justice
pendant des années l'avocat des leds
world pratique le droit depuis presqu'un
demi-siècle au texas il à willy garcia à
l'oeil depuis longtemps c'est un homme
très persuasif
il doit l'être pour parvenir à ses fins
les chasseurs d'ambulances le sont tous
des leds wade a déjà poursuivi garcia
dans une autre cause et le considèrent
comme le parfait exemple de chasseurs
d'ambulances des chasseurs attirés par
l'appât du gain qui se sont raffinées
avec le temps et qui continue de sévir
et pu nehmé tohmé pour moi ces gens
exploitent le deuil et la détresse comme
si les victimes n'étaient que des
morceaux de viande dans l'état de new
york
c'est une boucherie pour eux ces gens ne
sont qu'un morceau de viande pourrie
pour 15 mai que de l'argent
quelques mois
pour b les bulls il n'y a pas de doute
la présence de willy garcia sur les
lieux dans les jours suivant la tragédie
de lac-mégantic ne présage rien de bon
pour les victimes
on voit la jeune femme ce café était
environ
ici rue la nuit du 6 juillet pendant que
les gens fuient les flammes
pascal la fontaine roule à toute vitesse
vers le centre ville à la recherche de
son frère de sa belle soeur et de sa
femme karine le couple est très uni il a
trois enfants
une demi-heure avant j'étais là j'avais
laissé ma famille
ce turn avoir d'aller rechercher la
maman de mes enfants
cette nuit-là avec l'aide de quatre
hommes
pascal la fontaine se sert d'un de ces
tracteurs pour éloigner des flammes les
derniers wagons citernes et empêcher
qu'il n'explose à leur tour il le fait
au péril de sa propre vie aux derniers
jeux les faire peur
parce que envoya la catastrophe de
l'intérieur je savais très bien qu'ils
n'avaient aucune chance de retrouver
quelqu'un
au cur mme pascale trouve qu'après tout
s'est passé très vite sont arrivés avec
l'avocat québécois avec des avocats
américains qui ne parlait pas français
qui sont arrivés avec elle pas pu y voit
la housse mais je sais pas comment ils
sont arrivés dans le décor ça m'intrigue
un peu pourquoi aller si loin pour far
so le tir je sais pas je sais pas
vraiment pourquoi bly garcia at il
franchi les milliers de kilomètres qui
séparent sont exactes d'un talent du
québec et comment at il réussi à gagner
la confiance des proches des victimes
[Musique]
la vallée du rio grande et ses chants
ses granges et saisissent que récurrente
de corruption nous sommes à l'extrême
sud du texas
mais cannes est une des grandes villes
du comté tout près d'ici
la police des frontières surveille
étroitement le pont qui mène à reynosa
au mexique un camp de base des clowns
cartels de la drogue
l'économie américaine est celle du
mexique se rencontrent cet endroit les
pots de vin ne sont pas rares payer une
commission est une pratique enracinée
dans les moeurs
ça explique peut-être pourquoi la région
est un terreau fertile pour les
chasseurs d'ambulance à lorient
j'essaye larnack dénoncé dans cette
publicité consiste à recruter des
victimes pour ensuite fournir la kozah
des avocats au sud du texas
c'est une industrie nous sommes un
incubateur wifi ou c'est nous qui avons
montré comment faire au 30 rue
l'homme qui habite dans cette résidence
cossue de mais câline a la réputation
d'être parmi les plus habiles dans ce
métier willy garcia vite à l'abri des
regards mais l'ampleur de ses activités
ont été exposés au grand jour lors d'un
divorce acrimonieux en 2006 le couple se
dispute alors un ranch des objets de
luxe dont un picasso un délit et une
fortune amassée en parcourant la planète
la toile et que c'est ce qu'il m'a dit
oui à travers le monde et il choisit les
plus gros accident de paint michel
whitmore a travaillé pour beaucoup de
victimes d'accidents aux etats unis elle
est conseillère financière
experte en indemnisation la firme garcia
a fait appel à ses services en 2014
ils ont des gens qui sont déployés sur
le site
dès qu'un accident survienne à des
cadres de sos même ses détracteurs
reconnaissent le talent de garcia pour
recruter des clients permet les familles
des victimes
il faut dire qu'il sait s'entourer dans
une rare vidéos prises à son insu il ya
quelques années est obtenu par enquête
il raconte candidement son association
avec des proches de rien de moins que
l'ancien président mexicain vicente fox
[Applaudissements]
la cei
willy garcia utilisait le réseau
consulaire du mexique
il avait des bureaux à l'époque pour
approcher des victimes en brisgau cloud
gauche pipeau il utilisait ces personnes
pour trouver des cas qui survenaient
ailleurs dans le monde
que ce soit en indonésie en espagne en
russie ou en juge
ils m'ont s'est raconté que lors de
certains écrasement d'avion en europe
lui ou un des siens étaient sur les
lieux en moins de 24 heures et il en
était très fier et c'est
vraisemblablement ce qu'ils oublient
garcia fait un nouveau mi 2013 pour
surveiller la tragédie de lac mégantic
j'ai appris que très rapidement
quelqu'un de la firme garcia est arrivé
à lac-mégantic was in black magic pour
approcher les familles des victimes et
les convaincre de signer une entente
avec eux willy garcia est bel et bien
l'homme qui a convaincu ginette cameron
d'engager des poursuites aux états unis
moi je me suis dans le fond c'est vrai
que peut-être il faut quelqu'un qui paye
pour solent mais on a pris les gens qui
étaient le finalement sans connaître
personne au total des proches de 40 des
47 disparus ont signé avec ces mêmes
avocats
on ne signale simplement c'est comme
dans ma tête c'est comme j'avais comme
paul schultz et lost et comme je l'avais
peu tard mais j'étais pas dans un étau
pour faire prendre une décision en ce
moment personne n'avait la taille est à
dire nous allons prendre un table pour
réfléchir on s'est fait vraiment poussé
à dire
nous sommes là pour faire signer pour
vous représenter faites nous confiance
après la nuit terrifiante du 6 juillet
pascal la fontaine est confrontée à une
ultime épreuve j'étais faire le pire
travail le pire
la chose la plus dure que deux personnes
à faire à dire je partis rejoindre à
faire et leur annoncer qu'il n'avait
plus le même
donc imaginez vous dans cet état
d'émotions l'eau vous arrivez dit c'est
oublié c'est l'homme savait pas le choix
[Rires]
c'est intrusif et sa mise sous ma
fragilité des victimes on leur demande
de prendre une décision qui aura un
impact décisif sur leur fille un moment
ils ne sont pas apte psychologiquement à
le faire de son côté 1,2 merci reconnaît
que les gens étaient bouleversés mais
ils estiment qu'ils ont signé de façon
libre et volontaire une chance à risque
faisait les gens ont pris une décision
informée il
mais joseph comment on arrêtait deux ou
trois au mont après
je pense pas au clash de la décision
aurait été différent pourtant au québec
les normes déontologiques recommande la
plus grande prudence aux avocats lorsque
des clients sont vulnérables nous ont
rencontré les gens puis avait pas de
pression certainement point du il y
avait un peu de jus d'avant ce qui est
un peu normal dans n'importe quel métier
mais josé on est procureur notre job
c'est pas de vendre une salade ou il
faut qu'on fasse valoir mon service
c'est quoi les avantages de prendre ce
recours
mais quel est l'avantagé d'agir si vite
pris à une presse la loi accorde deux
ans aux victimes pour engager des
poursuites aux états unis qu'on nous
demande de d'entrée latence combo lol
tout de suite
moi je trouve que ça n'avait pas de bon
sens qu un genre en soi pourquoi
l'urgence pour des sous cet empressement
est inquiétant mais serait typique de la
manière dont billy garcia a procédé dans
le passé une des raisons pour lesquelles
les chasseurs d'ambulances dépêchent de
déposer une poursuite c'est pour
devancer la concurrence
ils poursuivent avant même d'enquêter
sur l'accident
tout cela rappelle des souvenirs
pénibles à rené guérin l'ancien
procureur en chef n'est pas surpris que
willy garcia se soient retrouvées à
lac-mégantic 10 4 ans il a maîtrisé
l'art et la exporter il a maîtrisé l'art
oui il est très bon n'est ce pas il s'en
est bien tiré ici je suis sûr qu'il n'a
pas honte de ce qu'il fait et qu'il est
convaincu d'aider les gens en échange
d'une somme d'argent
prenez guerra est tout de même hanté par
willy pas seulement parce qu'il a été
incapable de l'arrêter mais parce que
c'est son propre petit cousin de jeu les
renier tout simplement
eide dont les verts je crois que c'est
mal d'exploiter les sentiments des gens
pour en tirer une forme de bénéfices si
willy garcia est parvenue jusqu à lac
mégantic
c'est qu'il a trouvé une complice qui
lui permet d'agir dans l'ombre sa fille
mais oui garcia
lac mégantic la loi le monde entier a
les yeux tournés vers lac-mégantic dans
les jours suivant la tragédie où les
gars y allie est déjà là dans les
coulisses rappelez vous on s'interroge
toujours sur les causes de l'accident
et surtout on compte encore les victimes
quand son équipe décroche la première
poursuite
c'est seulement après que van persie
reçoit un coup de fil
la firme myers 1 flower de chicago qui
s'est joint à celle de bully cherche
l'aide d'un avocat québécois
j'ai été contacté par les avocats
américains parce que les écouter ça nous
prend un procureur local ce poste un
dossier premièrement cause de la
barrière de langage l'eau qui nécessite
la la la la présence de quelqu'un et
aussi quelqu'un de damas qui connaissait
le droit local parce que vous
comprendrez assiette d'avoir conseils
pour césar colle aussi flowers et
garciaphone tadic
webster une autre firme qui tu exerces
le groupe de litige en catastrophe
ferroviaire
le 24 juillet mouly garcia réserve
pendant dix jours une salle au motel le
quillier ou lieu les rencontres avec les
victimes
or quand on le questionne sur la
présence de willy garcia l'avocat hans
mercier qui était à ses côtés à
lac-mégantic n'a aucun souvenir
oui les gars hier à vous l'avais pas
rencontrée c'est possible je t'ai jeu
comme moody's ou sauce et des choses
passées des gens qui étaient surtout
c'était ce que par rapport à la au
premier docile qui avait été référé
le mystère plane sur la manière dont la
firme garcia a obtenu ce premier cas
avant de le référer un autre local
aurait servi d'intermédiaire auprès de
la famille mais personne n'a voulu nous
parler un avocat peut référer le dossier
mais seulement dans des cas précis c est
à rappeler b les douanes sont réfère un
dossier pour des raisons d' expertise
pas ça de l'art mac il faut être
impliqué comme avocat dans docile
on ne peut pas l'obtenir dans le but de
le refiler à l'autre
juste pour encaisser nous avons tenté
d'en savoir plus sur le film garcia des
recherches dans les registres officiels
du texas révèle que la firme a été
enregistrée le 13 ou 2013 soit un mois
après la tragédie et après le dépôt de
la première poursuite
la firme est au nom de maria mairie
garcia c'est mary garcia l'avocat de la
firme jane lynch tout comme je dis moi
je prends pour moi était déjà avec gie
poe et et j'ai pas eu d'interlocuteur à
cette ferme à la loi des documents
déposés au cours au texas lors du
divorce des garcia nous éclaire sur son
identité
mary est en fait la fille aînée de willy
au moment de la tragédie
mais oui car ce n était diplômé en droit
que depuis quatre ans meriem a dit
qu'elle ne fait aucun travail juridique
je ne sais même pas si elles rencontrent
les clients
le rôle de la firme a été très limitée
reconnaît inde merci comme on dit c'est
une firme qui a pas été très active au
niveau de la du lit de ces jo plus
encore le droit n'intéresserait pas
vraiment mairie je ne veux pas vraiment
faire ce travail je fais assez d'argent
ça me déplacer un jour mon père m'a dit
j'ai besoin d'un avocat dans la famille
alors tu vas aller faire ton droit je
les fais et à la fin je vais balancer
mon diplôme sur la table et j'ai dit
tiens voilà ton avocat
parmi les dizaines de personnes et qui
nous avons parlé à lac mégantic
aucune ne se souvient dit avoir vus mais
oui garcia selon michel whitmore elle ne
servirait que d'écran pour les activités
de son père d une cage mais je crois que
l'entente est entre l'a fait un garcia
c'est à dire mairie garcia et les
clients ensuite j'ai cru comprendre que
willy qui dans les faits est celui qui
dirige le processus trouve un avocat qui
agit à titre de conseiller et qui
s'occupe de la poursuite judiciaire la
firme s'est pourtant présenté aux
victimes de lac-mégantic comme un grand
cabinet ayant des bureaux dans plusieurs
villes et offrons toute la gamme des
services juridiques hans mercier dit
avoir fait les vérifications d'usagé
banqueter - ge comme osez j'ai fait
validé au niveau de ses cabinets look
est effectivement des cabinets existants
est ce que j'ai fait la vérification sur
tous et chacun des employés des
procureurs leur statut non une simple
visite sur son site web confirme que
mary garcía et l'unique avocate d'un
modeste bureau situé à mais câline willy
et mary garcia nous répondu ni à nos
appels né à nos nombreux courriels et à
leur bureau
on nous ya d'abord réformer qu'ils
étaient absents
quand nous avons insisté pour rentrer on
nous a répondu qu'il n'y avait personne
de ce nom à cet endroit
les firmes webster à miles and flowers
n'ont pas voulu répondre à nos questions
la fillette de mma a mené à la
constitution d'un fonds d'indemnisation
auquel presque toutes les compagnies
visées par les poursuites ont contribué
les victimes ont pu se partager 114
millions de dollars
est-ce qu'on a contribué très
certainement parce que c'est mon temps à
l'eau pensez vous sincèrement que des
défendeurs à réveiller c'est mon talent
aussi avait pas une crainte d'être
poursuivie aux états unis pour des
montants comme sont les familles
représentées par garcia et son groupe
ont payé pour la plupart les honoraires
de 40 % des tarifs courants aux états
unis mais le chiffre a fait sursauter le
juge québécois chargé d'approuver le
règlement à faire aux victimes des
hommes qui font montre de luxe de
commercialité si je me souviens de mon
code de déontologie des avocats mais
écoutez 40 30 millions c'est pour avoir
cours et à boîte à malle plus vite les
autres là parce que au final le montant
des honoraires dépasserait 40 millions à
elle seule la firme garcia aurait réussi
entre 10 et 15 millions de dollars selon
notre évaluation mais ça ne lui a pas
suffi nous avons découvert qu'elle a
tenté d'obtenir une part de la
commission sur le travail fait par la
firme de michel whitmore un montant qui
aurait pu atteindre quelques centaines
de milliers de dollars
willy a été très clair sur le fait qu'il
s'attendait à être payé pour ce travail
il m'a dit tu sais mais c'est comme ça
que je fais mon argent c'était chaud est
tellement flagrant et d'une telle à
visiter j'étais dégoûté
peu après leur différend michel whitmore
a été remercié de ses services en
novembre 2015
elle a ensuite tenté d'alerter des gens
de lac-mégantic de 6,5 ce sont des
décisions importantes et je ne voulais
pas que les gens soient à nouveau
victime
willy garcia est depuis retourné dans
l'ombre les gens de lac-mégantic ne
l'ont jamais revue non plus c'est qu'on
ne l'ait jamais revue parce que dans
matin c'est lui qui m'ont fait signer le
comprenez mais en signant les gars y en
a peut-être commis une erreur ce n'est
pas mary l'avocate qui a apposé sa
signature sur les contrats qui lient la
firme aux familles
c'est son père or willy n'est pas membre
du barreau du texas là dessus des leds
worlds est formel ce n'est pas permis
aux non l'employé d'une firme ne peut
pas signer un contrat
parce qu'ici c'est la signature de willy
non il n'a pas le droit de signer un
contrat juridique nos règles interdisent
qu'est ce que ça fait ce ça peut annuler
le contrat
est-ce qu'en faisant ça ils se fait
passer pour un avocat
oui absolument
les familles pourraient avoir des
recours et peut être récupérer certains
honoraires surtout dans le cas des
orphelins je ne suis pas expert en droit
canadien du bel edward mais ici je
détruirai ce contrat quant aux activités
douteuses de willy révélé lors de son
divorce et les allégations sur son passé
de chasseur d'ambulances hans mercier a
paru surpris c'est quelqu'un qui
recrutent des victimes d'accidents et
qui vend les corps des avocats
mais c'est illégal c'est ce qu'on
appelle aux états unis du bar et riz
écoutez c'est des reproches que
j'entends pour la première fois ceux des
reproches avec égard que je ne peut
valider au moment où on se parle
hans mercier nous a dit qu'il allait
vérifier nos informations mais qu'à son
avis personne n'a été lésé
je me sens pas mal à l'aise par rapport
au service comptait donner à ces gens là
je me sens pas du tout mal à l'aise par
rapport au travail qui a été fait dans
ce dossier l'eau et où le judoka été
obtenues et ou circonstances dans
lesquelles ont été faites en ce merci
affirme avoir sollicité personne
quelques familles nous ont pourtant dit
avoir reçu un appel de son bureau
si la firme garcia a obtenu des cas de
cette manière afin de les vendre
ce ne serait pas qu'il moral ce serait
carrément illégales selon bel edward
gars y adhérer sans doute qu'il a vu aux
intérêts de ses clients en les confiant
des avocats compétents
ce n'est pas lui le faire lorsqu'il agit
de la sorte ils en feraient la loi
ça en fait qu'un criminel mais comment
aurait-on pu protéger les victimes de
lac-mégantic de gens comme les garcia la
planète avait pourtant des yeux rivés
sur la ville
mais ni les pouvoirs publics ni le
barreau n'ont pu veiller aux intérêts
des familles immensément vulnérables
plusieurs ont le sentiment d'avoir été
laissés à eux mêmes sarr était tellement
important parce ce moment-là avoir eu
déjà à plein neutralité qui viennent
prêter main forte au point de vue
juridique
sarr était tellement important
au final près de la moitié de l'argent
amassé pour les familles endeuillées et
alliés à leurs avocats
cet argent lloyd et aux enfants sans
jamais été pour les aider à surmonter
liberté se rendre compte que déjà qu' à
aucun rien par rapport il qui viennent
piger dans le pot ça pharma et où la
conscience aujourd'hui les bat de la
tragédie risque de se faire sentir
encore longtemps à lac mégantic la santé
publique rapporte le taux élevé de
détresse chez les proches des victimes à
la perte s'ajoute maintenant un
sentiment de trahison
déjà quand les gens beaucoup bookbook
pnj annexes arrive je dire on s'en
remettra jamais probablement mais que
quelqu'un faso a déjà un vénérable comme
nous l'ont c'est impossible on peut pas
prendre un peu potache
aucune somme ne pourra jamais combler le
vide laissé par les disparus mais le
règlement devait aider les victimes à
retrouver un sentiment de justice une
justice dont ils auront finalement
doublement payer le prix